Racist.
Do you know how I'm going to do that?
I'm going to shit all over this racist,
this racist Rosanna.
They don't care if you're really racist.
But the thing that gets me about it is
it's, I'm going to shit all over this Jew.
Yeah.
Because I was talking about Iran as a
Jew and speaking about Persian Jews and,
uh, you know, all kinds of error. Can
you talk to them about complexity?
It is complex, but I always was
on there talking, uh, you know,
defending or, you know, speaking
for Jewish people. And so,
you know, I just, I think
that in the long run,
I really want it to be known that I
am a Jew and was speaking as a Jew.
And when I spoke about the Iran
deal and its effect on, uh,
Jewish people in the Middle East,
and I really thought first
they didn't know that,
but now I think, well, they
had to know some of it.
I don't think they want to know.
This is what I think you say.
Someone says that's a black woman.
What does she one eighth black,
like what is she? Um, something very
small, 46% or something. Really?
Yeah. She had her DNA done
was talking about it. Oh.
And 40 something allocation
and it doesn't look good,
but whatever,
whatever.
We can't tell who people are by
how they look on 1.6% African.
Cool. Awesome. That's
the heart of the world.
When you look at what happened.
I think it's real simple.
I think she identifies where people
identify her as a black woman.
You said planet of the Apes Racist.
Yeah. Boom. It's that simple.
I don't think they give a fuck of,
you're a Jew.
I don't think they care
if you're not racist.
I think this is a viable target
when they go out so well,
I said I voted for Trump. I was a
target that too, that too. And then,
and then they can find a, a tweet from
the past. Let's not forget either.
Oh yeah. My got in trouble for that
long many times. Yeah. You know,
there's just things you can't say and
then there's worse things that you can.
So it's weird cause they don't censor
anybody who's, you know, calling for, uh,
you know, to kill all the Jews. There's
thousands of them. They don't give.
You shared about the not famous women
with sitcoms. Yeah, they are who, uh,
you know, people that are, are
tweeting support for Valerie Jarrett,
uh, you know, are pissed at me and
saying, how could you say this about,
they're not saying that because they're
saying kill the juice. They did,
did don't they don't maybe know
what your point was. I didn't know.
Like I didn't know about her
parentage. I mean, come on. This is,
this is the truth. This is who I
am. And you know, they, they uh,
they did this too, but they're
not really saying kill the Jews.
It's not like a valid comparison.
Well, I'm a Jew. I understand that.
But the people that, that's how it feels.
Maybe it feels that way. Yeah, it does.
But the people does to
a large number of us,
they're upset at you because they think
you said something. I know they're not
saying kill the Jews.
Well, but they are to us.
Okay. You see how when people
look at your situation,
I can see how they think,
but,
but you see how when people look at your
situation and they think it's racist,
that is also how you look at,
they're reacting to what they think is
racist and you thinking that they're
saying kill all the Jews.
Well they're saying like, uh, you know,
Iran every day threatens the Jewish
people in Israel with annihilation and
they've already survived, you know,
not too long ago. An annihilation. So,
and then we make a deal with
that government. What does
that does say something.
I understand that,
but this is many steps past.
But to me that you said a racist thing
or thinking you said a racist that they
think I said a racist thing. Yeah,
I understand that completely.
They have no idea that this had
anything to do with Jews versus Iran.
They really don't have any idea that,
I've never seen that.
I've never seen that registered by the
people that are upset at you because it's
not important enough to
them to know that well,
it's probably not been explained
to them. Yeah. For one,
I know your position like this,
like you're,
you're talking about now I understand
that they might not even think it's valid.
Like if they went back and went over it,
how might disagree with the
political aspects of it. Yes.
And they're free to do that. I'm not
going to try, but they're not alive.
You know what I'm saying?
Like they're not,
the reason why I said it's
not a valid comparison.
They're not really saying kill the Jews,
but to me and to other Jews, they
are in fact saying that. And,
and that's very common amongst
us. So you know, that's,
that's the truth that many of us think.
And you know it, people are
understand it or they don't, you know,
care to even consider it.
Well, they don't have to,
but I'm still going to say it
because that's the reality.
It's the reality.
To hear that and to hear the United
States went and gave them billions of our
tax dollars when they're the number
one supporter of terror in the world.
It is.
And they always do kill Jews like
in Paris and wherever else they go.
And they do it in London too. I mean,
you know, I hate to wake people up,
but you know,
it is important.
At least it is to me and to people
like me and to many other people,
many Christians,
it's very important to them too.
They're there under onslaught too.
I'm not exactly sure what you're talking
about because you're talking about
Iranians killing people
in Paris and England.
No, I'm talking about being the number
one sponsor of terror in the world. Iran,
but they're killing people in France
and England. Yeah. That are Jews.
When,
when is this happening?
Well, when they that theater
and a lot of other times,
but there's a lot of babies that
all Jewish woman to death and,
and her Paris apartment,
there's a lot of it.
I'm not saying they only killed Jews,
but they do kill deuce
and the money goes back to those
terrorist organizations that are funded by
Qatar and Iran. Okay. This is a,
this is a pretty, these, these are
general things you're saying, right? Yeah.
It's very general and there's a hundred
shades. There's a hundred shades.
But I'm just saying as a
Jew with a family in Israel,
this is what we think and
that this is how we feel.
And to not even acknowledge that and
any discussion is kind of disturbing.
It should be factored in. I don't think
it's a matter of not acknowledging it.
I think she'll be factored in as well.
They're aware that this had anything to
do with your motivation? Well, I'm out.
I've never read it anywhere. You
can't say it. That's what I'm saying.
He can't say it.
It's not really a smiled on to,
uh, go against the, uh,
people who control our media and say,
especially,
uh,
social media and say that you're a pro
Israel or you know, that you think,
um,
okay.
You don't think that the media will
allow you to be pro Israel. I mean,
that seems like a really common thing.
Not on social media for the most part. No,
it's very anti Israel. You'll,
I'll send you statistics. Well,
I see some anti Israel sentiment,
especially in relation to a,
they treat the Palestinians
like I see a lot of that.
Yeah. Well, I, I'm not going to
play into either of those because I,
I really believe that, uh, you know,
there's a solution to that problem.
The solution is pacing and
I think it can be achieved.
So I'm not going to play either one of
those games about who does this and what.
I just like to see a solution that works
for all the people. They're all people.
They're so, um, but it can't be. Yeah,
but it can't be,
if one side has been
completely censored and it,
that isn't a discussion or is it a
debate and nor is it an American scary.
It's scary times when, you know,
like on our college campuses today,
I know this because my son
was on one and uh, you know,
it's a far left.
They're far left,
professors that espouse that kind of
stuff daily. And all of our colleges.
And it does find its way to the media.
You look at the media that most,
what are they called, millennium
millennials consume and it's heavily,
uh, to the left. It is. Yeah.
And so that's where they're
informing. They're, they,
they are getting their opinions from
only hearing one side of things on social
media.
And I don't think that's good.
I don't think it's good that all
conservative voices are being censored off
Twitter. You know, and well
not all, I shouldn't say all,
but so many are because that's a
way to shut down discussion too.
There's quite a few conservative voices
on Twitter, but some are when they,
they think they're inflammatory or they
think they're espousing hate. Yeah. Yeah.
But they get to decide that.
But deciding that it's people
who are heavily political. Yes,
yes. That's not right. It should be
companies lean left, all of them.
It should be more in the
middle where we're both sides
are considered to come to.
That's what consensus
means is a diverse opinion.
And that's how you reach consensus.
You don't get a consensus.
So Nora solution from only listening to
one side blather on the same ship for 20
years. That keeps people fighting at each
other, not only to keep people fighting.
I think it recruits
people for the other side.
I think it does the opposite
of its intended effect.
That's what one of my friends said.
He said he thinks Michael Moore,
that's Michael Moore's role
since he's a billionaire too,
that he's a billionaire. Well, they said
this is what they said. I don't know.